you said you had a story but we're gonna
get well i wanna touch that but you said
you had a story before go on um i've
even been in a situation where
like my ex has told me what she needs
and i haven't done that
and that's what would lead up to a
breakup because she she basically she
wrote a letter like saying that what she
wants within a relationship
and
i read that as a man and i said i can't
offer that
you know i mean i can't offer that you
know what i mean and
i heard that and she left
and do you think she found a man that
would do it
they she can't end the day no but do you
think she yeah i think she has yeah okay
so it was so it wasn't that
it wasn't outlandish because it wasn't
our lunch because it was thinking we're
like
i'm in the day like
we've we've done this in it
we
we've been traveling like for months
i was like we're like i don't think i
could do this like i can't adapt to it
but i feel like later
i kind of thought that i can
but this i thought
am i changing myself as a person to
adapt to her
i'm like
i don't know man
to read the super chat yeah
again
sentience thank you if your woman
challenges your character
she has someone else in mind she's
comparing you to
[Music]
yeah
you're saying yeah like it's the truth i
low-key agree
it's gonna sound so bad sorry sorry
woman to the woman who i'm just about to
expose you but
realistically if you're if there's
something like
if if you're coming at your man if
you're coming with these little
confrontations even if it's just sly
comments even if it's just little things
it means that
you envision
someone better it might be a physical
person that you already know like it
might be
your boy best friend or whoever else it
might be someone you actually know or it
might just be a fantasy of what you
think a man should look like by the way
if you if
you're constantly trying to change
little things about him it's because
you've seen better or you think you can
do better you envision
him to be someone else
interesting so women play those types of
games
you know you know what i call it
backup boyfriend
you see these guys best friends
you see these guys
no i don't think women see guy best
friends to me
men and women i don't have guy best
friends yeah i think i see i see that as
um
next in line
yeah yeah i see it as next in line yeah
i think
i see that i think they got backups
even so because casa is a guy man come
on man
do you want to be in a position as a boy
best friend you understand you you want
to you know that
you're next in line if this if her
current relationship messes up i want to
ask a question is it the title or is it
the friendship because
do you have female friends i don't have
female i don't i have female friends but
i don't have female best friends okay
but that's what i'm saying is it the
title is it the relationship i don't
have any female friends
no because you're either a potential
something or not
wow
[Music]
what like what am i doing with a friend
i don't
my friends are men
as a man if i if i'm keeping you around
or even if you're keeping me around i
know it's for a reason
i know it's because you're thinking um
that guy could be a i said i was in a
relationship for a long time okay i
understood that
me keeping a woman around while i'm in a
relationship would be detriment to my
relationship
like on the flip side if she's keeping a
guy around that could be detrimental to
my relationship so i kind of quickly
learned that as i became single been
single like three years now yeah i
realized hang on a minute
why
do i need this specific woman as my
friend
do i find them attractive
is there something within the chemistry
between us
that could potentially turn into
something most of the time it's yes men
are more honest with that we'll be like
oh no you know what i tell women i tell
women all the time you don't have a guy
best friend yeah do you know what you do
to check if you've got a guy best friend
tell them to come around your house
a crazy
crazy time
and get some alcohol in him and then try
and put it on him if he says
what are you doing like crazy then he's
your friend if he says
all right cool i'll go i'll do it yeah
yeah your friend yeah he's just waiting
on his time he's waiting for his time
women don't have friends as men i'm
telling you men are
men are hunters like and the thing is
men are generally hunters we know it
and that's why when you guys hear a girl
that's got a guy best friend he's like
no you ain't got no friend man yeah you
ain't got a friend no no he's not your
friend because guys no guys that's what
i'm saying if the if the girls that i
call quote-unquote friends
called me up or text me at 12 o'clock
and say hey do you want to come around
yeah i'm just gonna i'm just chilling
i'll be like
all right cool
but i know what it's for
you're not gonna call me at that time to
come around your house even even so like
why do you need
like two male figures or support figures
in your life i think you should have
the men in women's lives that they
should be getting like
advice from should probably be older men
who have kind of been through some
things and can give you kind of advice
as to how you know what men do or your
family
this whole friend thing because i always
ask a woman
if you have a guy best friend tell me
how you met him
a lot of time like yeah well you know
what he chirps me but you know we kind
of decided that we're just going to be
friends yeah if he chaps you or you two
were going to do something that means
they're sitting attraction there
get out of here
um would you be okay with it if the if
the male best friend was before you
how would you how are you i would still
ask a question how did you become
friends
because a lot of women say that they got
friends but something happened between
them at some point and then now they're
just friends yeah if something happened
between you at some point that means
there's an attraction there you go
see i've got uh female friends but like
my kind of rule of thumb is like i'll
only have a friend if i know it's
completely platonic yes
i can never control from your side so i
can never control what they feel but i
would never disresp i'd never leave
sorry ugly no no no
i can't i can i can relate to him i feel
that though that's what i'm saying i
know i know ways i know it is as as
exact so if she put it on you if your
friend put it on you
you'd say no i'm saying no bro i'd say
no on the basis that i respect our
friendship he's a lie yeah
i even support his point i know
if i if if i'm not if i know that i'm
not feeling the girl in in that kind of
way i'm saying
cis
yeah it's that it's not adapting you
know what i'm saying put it this way
ugly
no no i shouldn't have no it's not even
ugly it's not even it's just thing where
like
you don't see them like that you
understand that you could they could be
attractive but
i don't feel you lacking that vibe yeah
so you could be a lame girl but bro i
don't you're your sister me bro okay
fair enough if the female adds value to
your life
like in certain ways shape or form i
don't know like if it's a situation
where it's like the advice that they've
given or like the business ideas
visions um and certain things like that
like i don't see why
it's you can't value that friendship in
fact over the your
sexual urges yeah i'm not saying that
you're going to go there yeah i'm saying
because if you see her like that it's
not like you're actively trying to go
there yeah i get it okay what i'm saying
in a certain setting
and she put on her feminine charms
you're going to be like
get off me you're crazy yeah men can do
something some man can do that i'm not
saying they can't because i've done it
okay i'm not saying they can't but i'm
just saying in general
men
will take the opportunity hundred
percent
you're not wrong about that they'll take
the opportunity
majority men were like oh free free
pom-pom yeah you're not wrong about that
yeah facts and think about it afterwards
oh we shouldn't have done that but those
are the those are the people that can't
that's not
like it's not normal yeah like you know
i mean they'll take the opportunity so
you actually believe men and women can
be friends yeah they they can they can i
think just because you're attractive
doesn't mean i'm attracted to you i
think
yeah i think if i know i don't want to
do anything i don't want anything with
you like that you are genuinely just my
friend i'm keeping that because i
disagree eventually the friendship will
end i it's not something i'm going to
keep around but i know from my side
i don't want this to go anywhere else
and that's it
and if it
if you try for it to go somewhere else i
will end the friendship i think women
know when a guy actually likes them oh
yeah
and they kind of keep them around they
do knowing that they can just keep them
when they're down
give them a call when they're
that's true
it's true guys get out of the friendzone
man
seriously get the hell out of the friend
zone be and pick up your balls and get
out of there all right the only time you
should be in the friend zone is when you
decide
if you want to be in there
i think because there's there's choice
i i think of me
i feel like majority of the like
the friendships that i have with women
i've decided to make that as a
friendzone thing
yeah you decided yeah i feel like i
decided yeah i've decided because i'm
the day
i can see you as a friend but there's
some qualities i don't like that i can't
i don't think
works in a relationship term of things
you know i mean you need that ick
yellow ache to put you off
this ick
this is real
she's not even wrong about it it's so
real it's a psychological thing once i
realize that you have something i like
i really value
even even if i s even if i tell myself
no spying i can look past it i could i
can't i just can't so what bug what
brings on the ick it's actually it's a
natural thing it's small things though
it's once i just what do you my question
is what do you see in a woman that makes
you feel like
oh
there's something there's definitely
something hold up
girls i understand the ick because girls
look to disqualify men but men usually
look to qualify yes like so the guys
generally don't have an itch we don't
have an ick we might have a reason guys
will have sex with a hole in the wall
okay cool and not know who's on the
other side yeah she's not wrong about
her let me here cool we talking about it
is there a hole there okay
there's some things i mean
there's something that's made me feel
like
like oh god
okay cool
i'll still see what's good like what's
going on by that oh but then again this
isn't the same as a relationship oh so
yeah but when but the thing is
relationship so i guess he's talking
about from a relationship from a
relationship standpoint yeah like he's
like oh there's things that put me off
you that i just physically wouldn't yeah
if you're looking for her as a
relationship type person
yeah yeah i get it but like i said a lot
of guys ain't even looking that far
ahead it's fair enough yeah they just
wanna you know they don't wanna smash
they wanna do the thing um